how many times a night you like that
fish stuff everybody it's Charlie this
is gonna be my non-spoilery Iron Fist
season 2 immortal weapons review I'll
also explain what's going on with
daredevil season 3 because Marvel just
released a whole bunch of information
about when we're gonna get footage
that'll also probably be telling us when
the premiere date is going to be so I'll
explain the timeline of where this fits
in to the other Netflix defender series
if you're new to the channel I'm doing a
new round of that spider-man ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this still waiting for spider-man
to show up somewhere in the defenders
universe all we need is a joke about
another guy that swings around in a red
costume on daredevil season 3 so we can
cross our fingers about that but on all
biggest changes from Iron Fist season 1
there are only 10 episodes of season 2
so Netflix has finally started to listen
to all your complaints about there being
too many episodes and too little story I
would expect that to continue with the
future seasons of all the other
defenders series - like Punisher Season
2 which they're finishing right now
Jessica Jones season 3 all the other
ones so they don't always have to be 13
episodes if they don't need to be you've
all probably seen the videos that I've
done about the way that they've upgraded
their fight choreography they got the
choreographer from Black Panther and
Creed to supercharge their kung fu
action scenes the Kunlun fight at the
beginning with me and Sasha was beyond
intense
but it really worked our asses off on
that and it broke us
but it looks great
so just in general it feels much more
like a classic kungfu gang war instead
of the boardroom drama that we saw
during season one now there are some
problems with pacing it still takes a
little while to get going even though it
is vastly better than season one in
general so I feel like if you were on
the fence about season 1 you'll probably
really like season 2 but if you flat-out
hated season 1 and you're confused about
why they renewed it for season 2 even
though it's better season 2 is it gonna
change your life or anything like that
they did do a good job of invoking more
immortal weapons iron fist history I've
talked about that in some of my trailer
videos they have flashbacks to Kon LUN
you start to learn more about that
hopefully if they do more seasons or
they do more with the character will
actually get to see in immortal weapons
tournament at some point but it's
through those flashbacks that you get to
see the classic comic book helm so
you've seen that in all the trailers but
he's fighting Davos
those are flashback scenes were there
wearing the white uniforms which is sort
of a wink at the white comic book
costume in present day he's wearing that
yellow face covering with the green
jacket so that's sort of the modernized
version of the Iron Fist comic book
costume that he's wearing at the
beginning of the series misty Knight is
one of the big crossover characters so
they are crossing people over on each
other series a lot more now like iron
fish showed up during Luke Cage season
two they've only released the first five
episodes for people to review Luke Cage
is nowhere in the first half of that I
don't expect to see him in the back half
either because this picks up after Luke
Cage season two misty Knight has her
bionic arm they do more daughters of the
Dragon and Colleen wing is now a
full-blown co-lead of the series so she
gets almost as much screen time as Danny
gets and all of her fight scenes in her
choreography during season one I felt
like was great so they just crank that
up to 11 but now there are physically
more fight scenes with Colleen wing
because she gets more screen time she
and misty Knight have a lot of funds
they bring a lot of the humor to the
series so does joy Meacham remember how
they spent so much of defenders making
fun of Danny's iron fist she shares a
lot of scenes with Davos so when he
eventually does get his iron fist like
you've seen in the trailers she
mercilessly teases him so they're not
pulling any punches with taking the piss
out of some of the characters that
they're bearing a little more self-aware
with the series like we know that you
thought that season 1 was
garbage we're trying to do better they
did do a good job of at least pushing
into some of the Iron Fist history and
mythology via the Orson Randall of it
all like the previous versions of the
iron fist so if you're big fan of that
fraction at Brubaker run there's a
little bit of that in there and
obviously the new big character is
typhoid mary the thing about her though
even though alice eve is a great actress
she is a slow burn so you're all waiting
for her to go crazy go to her alternate
persona where she's like this badass
ninja that just beats the crap out of
everybody it takes a while to get there
it's not like Luke Cage season one
molasses slow burn it's a little bit
quicker than that but it still feels
pretty slow compared to some of the
other elements of the series like you're
just kind of waiting for it to ramp up
to crazytown
they continue the tradition that all the
other Netflix Marvel series have had of
waiting to the halfway point in the
season in terms of episodes before
having a really big twist usually you
can set your watch by this like if you
feel like the first half of everybody's
season is really slow the second half is
where all the cool interesting hardcore
stuff is like I said they've only
released the first five episodes to
early reviewers so I'm expecting the
same deal with Iron Fist season 2 all
the cool stuff will probably be in the
back half of the season but remember is
only ten episodes total they did a
pretty good job with the Davos character
the actor did a good job with his fight
scenes we already learned in season 1
that he thinks the Dany is a trash Iron
Fist and the legacy belongs to him so
this just continues that arc where they
left off where he was talking to Jamie
Cheam forming an alliance Joey also
becomes a good foil for Ward in Dany
this season too because Ward is probably
one of the standout characters from
season 1 he's still great during season
[Music]
and if there was any question about the
timeline
remember this takes place relatively
soon after Luke Cage season 2 but before
daredevil season 3 so now you kind of
understand why they had to wait to do
daredevil season 3 because they had to
go through all these other arcs of
people dealing with what happened during
the defenders and then picking up the
slack now that they think that daredevil
is gone but obviously he'll be back so
by the time we get to daredevil season 4
hopefully we'll see some more kingpin
stuff crossing over to the other series
- what's going on with daredevil season
3 is the really good news they announced
they're bringing a panel to New York
Comic Con that's probably where they're
gonna drop the trailer they'll probably
have a title card at the end of that
that will confirm the release date I'm
expecting late November really early
December this is like the latest little
teaser that they drop with a little
question mark when they post it on
Twitter just letting you know where is
daredevil like yeah we're definitely
gonna be dropping the trailer really
really soon
[Music]
New York Comic Con is happening that
first week in October there's a bunch of
other trailers for other things that'll
be dropping then so I'll do videos for
all that stuff no worries I'll remind
people about the schedule when we get
closer what will happen next is is I
have some new Captain Marvel and some
new spider-man far from home videos that
I'm working on but leave all your Iron
Fist Marvel Netflix video requests in
the comments below if there's any
daredevil teaser I'll do a video for
that this weekend so be sure to check
out our fist if you have any big
questions just post them on the video
book TARDIS 3:9 for your the giveaway
winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my youtube
channel click here for that new venom
trailer with carnage Easter eggs and
click here for that Captain Marvel
official teaser thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight